bootleg head podcast man go watch my
full interview with this guy easy meal
uh dope combo check out his new music uh
he just signed with Eminem and Dr Dre so
hello
big deal kind of a big deal going on
all right we'll have him rap because if
you get signed by Eminem You Gotta come
and rap all right let's go
yeah
people tripping
but I bet they also kind of thinking
like if y'all been thinking how
defending lady
[Music]
[__] ever since you were born saying
that I wasn't snapping in the verse of
my song
you said what you said now I'm really on
whatever you want I could go against you
and little buddy hold on got you ass
folded hold symbol daddys I'm a shadow
clone the potato on the stick is how I
got you both scoping hoes and headaches
yeah imma let the owner know sit oh [__]
now they think I'm bogus 2200 tell them
what the coldest I'll never stop the way
I'm selling off these flow Blicks honey
badge I just barely all you cobras
little snaky teddy bears flexing
plagiarism you keep making money off my
name [__] you're very welcome huh feel
my reaction my Nuclear the way I hit em
up Earnest Critics on Street raps and
very subtle huh it's wide world to go
forward with the lyrics
[Music]
and they didn't raise no name to me it's
the trick hoes get money [__] to fame
yeah let it get to your head but I just
stay the same
okay
easy meal
Bodied
I appreciate you guys watching this
freestyle we got another one coming and
then another one and then another one
and they're all brought to you by our
good Folks at LRG clothing you already
know what it is LRG been keeping you fly
for years they got so much new fly gear
right now
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg when you
check out you'll save 30 off
l-r-g.com another freestyle is on the
way presented by LRG